a training regimen that topped his work
for the MCU the grueling three-month
shoot for extraction pushed Chris
Hemsworth to the Limit Hollywood is
often seen as a lot of smoke and mirrors
nothing is real and everything on the
screen is some trick of the camera
awesome skillful editing no action star
can actually do what we're seeing them
do right well not exactly the reality is
making movies isn't just creatively
demanding it's tough work physically as
well in the action genre in which actors
go to incredible lens to appear
legitimate unbelievable every punch kick
in one liner has to be expertly
choreographed and perfectly executed and
it's not easy just ask the star of
extraction Chris Hemsworth director Sam
Hargraves Thrill Ride of a film hit
Netflix back in 2020 and was met with
plenty of excitement by audiences who
showed up to make it the streamer's
biggest Premiere to that point most of
the discussions surrounding extraction
following its release centered on its
explosive action which made up the vast
majority of the film Hemsworth's Black
Market mercenary character Tyler rake is
ruthless in beating his opponents to a
pulp whether he has a gun or simply uses
his hands he turns out to be nigh
Unstoppable giving the Thor actor a
whole new action hero into which to sink
his teeth but he's not the only one who
deserves credit for the fight scenes and
extraction the commitment of everyone
involved is something to be commended
setting up such fast-paced and elaborate
combat sequences is no small feat as
Chris Hemsworth admitted training for
such scenes was rigorous since the movie
is largely just a series of action
scenes the actor had his work cut out
for him the old saying goes practice
makes perfect and thus a phrase easily
applied to Chris Hemsworth training to
become Tyler rake when revealing how
intense the process was he confessed to
Netflix film that the physical work was
incredibly challenging that said he
ultimately compared the process to
memorizing lines of dialogue the best
strategy he found for learning his moves
was simple repetition going head first
into the choreography over and over
again until it became second nature
brain is a muscle and that's a muscle
and that's a muscle and they are all
muscles this is all muscle so I am
covered in brain with constant
repetition Hemsworth malice to
familiarize himself with each step
weaving has seen the sequence of moves
into well-paced and entertaining combat
Hemsworth noted that it was an intense
process that never slowed down saying
every day we were shooting one scene
would be rehearsing the next fight scene
the following day in other words the
Australian exit was pulling double duty
every day to ensure that choreography
was just right but just because they
were doing so much at once doesn't mean
it was a quick process
so it didn't really stop and it was a
three-month shoot and basically kind of
running and sprinting and fighting the
whole time Peggy backing from fight to
fight is an intense feat and it sounds
like Hemsworth had a grueling time while
shooting extraction but just how intense
was that experience compared to other
roles obviously Chris Hemsworth was no
stranger to starring in action movies
before he got the leading role in
extraction as a major player in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he's been part
of some of the 21st Century's most
popular and ambitious action-packed
Blockbusters however the actor had to
step up his game for the Netflix
Thriller telling news.com.eu the whole
thing was by far the most exhausting
shoot I've ever been a part of going
into the movie Hemsworth was already
familiar with Sam Hargraves who the
director's previous stunt coordination
work with Marvel but even with that
personal connection the intensity of the
extraction shoot still took him by
surprise despite all the challenges
Hemsworth was more than up to the task
even better he set to reprise a role of
Tyler rake in a sequel extraction 2
which is set to premiere on Netflix 6 in
June 2023
[Music]